je vais voter pour manuel valls et je
soutiendrai parce que dans cette
primaire est ensuite dans l'élection
présidentielle je n'imagine pas que le
débat ait lieu devant les français entre
des candidats à la présence de la
république qui tous soit en jambes
soient piétine
ce quinquennat est le bilan que nous
portons et je crois que le bilan que
nous avons bien sûr il y à des
frustrations
bien sûr il y a des résultats qui ont
été longs à venir
et il ya aussi des succès et des choses
très fier ou en particulier dans mon
secteur je pourrais vous parler de mes
sujet de fierté est donc bien entendu il
est indispensable que à mon sens le
candidat qui représentera le parti
socialiste et la gauche
plus largement dans cette élection
présidentielle soit aussi porteur du
bilan je crois que les français n'y
comprendraient rien s'il n'avait
personne pour représenter ce quinquennat
la gauche à gouverner cinq ans et elle
ne peut pas être absente du débat
deux à la fois du bilan mais aussi du
projet donc si je vous comprends bien
votre et valser vous le soutiendrez
parce qu'il défendra bien le bilan de
françois hollande jeu mais c'est le sien
au cices notre bilan collectif et je
bien sûr c'est un bilan collectif le
bilan de françois hollande 17 bilan
d'une majorité parlementaire également
c'est un bilan que nous portons tous